so eileen goo uh i think we had spoken
about this last week patreon last week
patreon okay eileen gu uh has won gold
in um freestyle skiing eileen goo born
in america raised in america trained in
america yes half chinese uh
family moves i think when she's how old
to china well actually i don't even know
if they went she plans to go to stanford
college here but
in order to compete for china she has to
be a chinese citizen and china doesn't
allow dual citizenship oh really yeah
this is where it gets a little
interesting
but she won't answer the question
that's just kind of fun red will let it
slip
go go go red bull basically said that
they're her main sponsor that she gave
up her citizenship and then reporters
tried to confirm that they scrubbed the
convo so it's still not clear where
there's another chinese-american zoo yi
who's being blasted by the entire skater
and then you get blasted by china that's
time it's a different 500 million people
because that zoo didn't [ __ ] win uh
win gold this girl won gold uh what i
think what is annoying about this whole
situation is uh there's a couple things
one is like she one won't address the
whole citizenship thing but also she
won't just admit that she got paid yeah
just like stop oh i care about my
heritage and this is all about embracing
my hair shut the [ __ ] up you or your dad
got a boatload of money okay you got
tons of [ __ ] money i know her father
i think was offered some job there i
believe so i gotta double check that but
yeah i'm pretty sure he's like an ai guy
so there might be some sort of like
thing we had to accept but you got paid
a [ __ ] ton of money you took that
[ __ ] money you announced your
citizenship okay you were raised trained
in the united states of america you plan
on coming back to school here so don't
give me this oh i love my hair to
someone we'll stay there you love it
somebody's right there yeah you're
competing for them right you won't go
for them why do you want to come back
here clearly you'll have something else
over here but we're not giving that
boatload of money that they're giving
you or they're giving your family or
something else yeah like that but this
is a [ __ ] money play yeah there's no
way in [ __ ] hell that anybody would
choose china over america ever unless
they got paid a shitload of money for
anything yes i don't care what you want
to do you want to run around on a
[ __ ] thatched roof you can find one
in america to run around on what if they
gave her some other deal for example i
don't know like if there's like a
sponsorship thing so it's not direct
money but it's like hey you're going to
be the biggest star in china or you can
be like
10 stars it's money and also but here's
the thing fairness how much could she
make being a freestyle skier in america
like we give them all these props during
the olympics but they're not making
besides a few people like this that you
get
she's cute she can make money she's a
victoria's secret she got signed by
victoria's secret so she's gonna have
her own other should grade sponsorship
100 should make great sponsorship money
100 i'm sure that they're paying her
family or they're paying her far more
money far more and i get that you're
doing that my point is don't
skirt around answering the question
about citizenship and then don't act
like this is an embracement of your
heritage because it's not that you're
embracing money which you probably
learned to do in america right we put
that [ __ ] in you sure love some [ __ ]
about that though you have to pretend
it's about love of culture yeah but i'm
going to call you out
fair enough that's all i think yeah i i
i think it is a money play but also it
could also be she just wants to be a
superstar and she knows that over there
she's going to be a superstar they
idolize her look more yeah like
she just she gave up american
citizenship to come over here so they're
going to probably acknowledge that well
still like she could play for both teams
yeah they're going to prop her up
because they're going to be like hey
others do the same [ __ ] so it's like she
wants to be a superstar it might not
just be the money i hear what you're
saying like she wants that fame and
maybe cares about that fame yeah she
won't be able to she wants to be an idol
where here she wouldn't be that big what
is that plus money like because it seems
like you're suggesting that they're
paying her directly like yo come compete
direct or indirect
this is a financial gain that's what
this is about
because you're still coming back here to
go to college like if you love your
heritage and everything so much and you
just love the lifestyle in china go get
educated there clearly they have you
know great institutions they're making a
lot of engineers say again she's half
chinese half well now she's 100 chinese
right she's a chinese citizen yeah but i
mean she could like both of her
priorities my feeling is you're not
chinese
yeah you're not indian
i'm not scottish we are american that's
what the [ __ ] we are now i know you
identify certain ways but let me just
make the point i'm trying to make when
it comes to the olympics you shouldn't
even be allowed to do that [ __ ]
where you go
uh compete for
your heritage's
country like where your mom is from or
something like that like i know
americans do that when they're not good
enough to you know play for the american
team right that's valid i'm okay with
that i'm not okay with that stop
stealing a [ __ ] position on that team
from someone who actually is raised born
trained in that country that's fair
you're stealing their opportunity fair
you had so much more privilege training
in america you had so much more
privilege growing up here with the
institutions the education even within
your within your field and you're
stealing it from someone who actually
represents their country what if they
don't have an athlete in that sport say
again what if they don't have an athlete
in that sport then they shouldn't
compete in it
some of you can be jamaican sorry
if they don't have an athlete in it and
it doesn't reflect the culture at all
then you're just finding a way to get
into olympics on a caveat like no if
they don't care about it it's not worth
it then no no we're not what about the
ball players who were playing in their
country started balling out in the
country and then america took him for
the nba but that's the thing that's
different that's professional olympics
they go back to play for their country
so instead of playing for the mb uh usa
team they play for they started playing
at their in their country yeah so you're
okay with that if they started to play
in their country if they were born
raised and trained in your country
that's where you should play okay 100
okay like if you were born race or at
least it's starting there like the
formative years yeah i know messi
technically went over to barcelona at
age [ __ ] 13 or something like that
but at least in his beginning years
that's where he's getting trained in the
sport right
and putting that time if you lived your
whole life as one citizen and then you
suddenly want to go play as another
citizen for the olympics he's saying
that's [ __ ] up and that doesn't make
sense you're stealing a job from that
the eileen goo point if i went and did
some [ __ ] for india i would live in
india afterwards for at least a long
time what at least what have you split
the europe so little new york florida
experience in europe
because china not letting you split the
citizenship up china no another country
what i'm saying like if you're a
jamaican chick living in canada you
learn how to curl you're pretty good at
curling you can't make the the canadian
team but you have jamaican citizenship
jamaica doesn't have a curling team and
you hit him up go yo let me crawl for
you guys you don't even have anyone
going let me just pop in that's also not
i'm okay with that that's also different
though no that's different because
you're not taking anything from anybody
i'm not taking a job you're just
like a fake way of doing it you might
inspire the sport to that country and
you're still making in canada like
that's what she's saying it's going to
happen in china you're being treated as
a jamaican you know i mean like you're
canadian but like you're still looked at
as a god you're so in love with this
girl dude yeah defending her at
everything because like now what about
the foreign players who come here to
play in the nba they're taking possible
positions from american basketball nba's
professional olympics is not
professional that's the distinction i
make for professional go ball in china
do all those things but olympics is not
professional because olympics is not is
it's supposed to be for country not for
self professionals for itself yeah i
don't really give a [ __ ] luca doncic
generally give a [ __ ] of the matter
all about professional leagues like i
love it when nba players go play in
turkey china any get your money dude
like and expand the game go there do
that like that's awesome but when it
comes for country like
i think that you have to represent a
country in order to represent the
country you have to [ __ ] know what
you're representing
like if you spent no time there you
don't have any kind of cultural impulse
from that country you don't even know
your own [ __ ] national anthem like
i'll be honest i don't know the scottish
national anthem joke
right
god save the queen
i don't know do you know the indian
national anthem
so it's like if we don't even know the
[ __ ] anthem dude who are we to go say
we're representing the country now
identity wise you can you you cannot
hide the fact that you're indian and
proud of all these things that are way
more important than a stupid anthem
they're americans that probably don't
know it but like
it's cap if you're like i feel like i
need to represent this thing no you
don't um can you you're just taking
advantage
of it who's somebody's farting and i
smell something i've farted many times
how dare you blame me how dare you
let it smell too that's even more
disrespectful because you could have
stopped
i can't i can only do one or two things
right it's like it was impossible for me
to formulate these arguments and hold in
the smell of a fart yeah are you really
okay have you smelled your own farts
dude yeah but i say something like a
gentleman what do you want me to do stop
talking about eileen goo for a second
yes exactly
real quick i farted sorry and then keep
going all right fair enough i'll do that
usually it's loud enough dude
yeah
actually i had to say something
yeah and it was so it's so strong i was
like it has to be from the person
closest to me can i tell you something
like geographically speaking i'm wearing
car hearts just like a work pant i
thought it would keep it in mostly and
it's not keeping it in at all dude i
think it's like a slow release it is a
dude literally i can feel it coming out
through the end i can see the fumes it's
like summer in texas it's just [ __ ]
it's just hovering right i almost put
the sock over the pants and just kind of
locked it in do you have a biohazard
suit yeah
i should have done that yeah i'll do
that next time i appreciate that thank
you does it smell that bad
yeah it really does i thought i was
getting used to it yeah you know
sometimes you get used to it then i
inhale i was like nah [ __ ] is [ __ ]
smelling so i feel like i've raised the
the temperature in the middle you have
though how does it taste but you have to
get warm it's spicy
that's what i thought was one of mine
for a second
it was so close to me i was like god
damn that must have been me
so so what do we do what is the uh
what's wrong with the jamaican [ __ ]
gonna play going to curl that's the only
thing i don't agree with like are you
spending time in jamaica like how
connected are you to the culture she
wants to be in the olympics yeah but
they don't have a team anyway you want
to be in the olympics [ __ ] work at it
well she's currently she's pretty good
no pretty good doesn't get you the
election in jamaica does but if she goes
there and wins all right fine you know
what i'm going to 23 and mia and find
out that i'm actually part ethiopian and
i'm going to go to ethiopia and make hey
guys i'd like to be a downhill skier do
you guys have anybody going that's
amazing you still wouldn't do this
you don't think i'd cut through the
[ __ ] wind with this nose dude are you
kidding me i would body these
[ __ ]
downhill i need to be way down we got to
go down right downhill skiing is just
who has is willing to kill themselves
more
oh yeah yeah that's it yeah you're not i
am not you're right
you're right i am risk-averse when it
comes to i don't even like heights i'd
be up there like yeah this is stupid
right yeah 100 yeah where's the short
track speed skating or something like
that yeah my son you get terrified on my
balcony remember back yeah i don't [ __ ]
with that also it looks like ethiopia
has a downhill ski too holy [ __ ] god
damn that's it
there's no way look at them
oh killing it
so yeah i'm like if there's no sport and
you want to go to the other country make
everything and you have a real attention
i'm going to keep it a buck dreadlocks
make it right yeah that's
a ski helmet is amazing
um yeah dude the jamaican girl that
wants to go do it for jamaica that's a
hypothetical i don't know that's true
but i'm just saying it's like you're
canadian dude like you were you taught
you were taught this game in canada
right you were trained by canadians to
be good at it like everything about you
and your connectivity to this game is
canadian
right now a different one is let's say
let's say for example
you are jamaican or you're argentine or
you're brazilian but you grew up in
america but everything about you playing
soccer
is argentina brazilian america hasn't
reinforced your love of soccer america
hasn't done anything to help you
flourish you spent your summers doing
these brazilian soccer camps and every
your family's been telling you guys like
everything about you loving soccer is
culturally brazilian or argentine to me
that's a better argument but you just
taking some canadian [ __ ] and being like
yo let me go to the olympics uh i'm kind
of i'm jamaican jamaica you got this
that's cheating bro be good enough to be
on that [ __ ] canadian team
nah i don't know why because i'm like
why should you have an advantage just
because your parents were born somewhere
else because you can inspire people in
jamaica are you inspired but you did
nothing
but you're not doing it to inspire you
do it because you want to go to the
olympics there's still a benefit that
comes from it even if you're being
selfish you might and then you're still
competing against how the [ __ ] they
gonna curl in jamaica
what are y'all talking about right now
right they bobsled in jamaica do they
yeah bruh
i seen the movie they didn't finish the
race but they walked that [ __ ]
killed themselves almost from the
bobsled sanka you're dead man
yeah
and you got to make a silver medal or
something which they'd be stoked on yeah
they don't have that many people in the
winter olympics so it's like oh [ __ ] we
got someone on the middle that's
definitely yes not good enough to make
the gold medal team which i assume is
canadian yeah but you think that you're
good enough to
win it all yeah
for jamaica even though you're doing it
with other people
so you compete against those guys and
you lose big deal
we'll give a [ __ ] you'll get better yo
yo
when we become socialists on this
[ __ ] podcast
we're just going to run to another
country and then take advantage of their
opportunity [ __ ] all that [ __ ] all that
yeah my parents did
that's what all of our parents did
exactly but at least they lived there
you know i mean they made a life yeah
you know they didn't give up their
citizenship and then stay there they
didn't go back
they didn't get american citizenship and
then go back yeah exactly because that's
what it was son this is bad for america
yeah that's why they did it that's why
they gave her the bag
they gave her the bag because they're
like oh they're she's willing to turn
her back on america america must not be
that great it's a great play however
much money they promised her was worth
every single penny
it was a brilliant play by china it's a
pr move people are willing to turn their
back on america for this other country
that other country must be more lit
and the fact that we let that happen and
we're letting her get off with this
whole i'm just embracing my culture [ __ ]
you are
yeah
[ __ ] you are she's doing damage to
america yes she is and she want to come
back and get educated here at stanford i
bet they got an institution over there
embrace your heritage over there yeah
embrace the [ __ ] out of it yeah
that's a good point 100 i don't like
this eileen goo
i don't like her
dove i know you love her i'm sorry i
mean she's hot
objectively hot objectively yeah and
that's the american side it makes it
mixed with that [ __ ] chinese city
yeah that's a pretty goddamn good
combination
we gotta come together america and china
we make some beautiful people oh yeah
that's true pb j that's right pb and jay